if you is the opportunity to create your
own spider-man not one that was in this
movie anything you want any style of
animation what would you pick and why I
gotta say I know it's gonna sound like a
stock answer but they already did that
for me I like Peter B Parker and I like
this animation I like the way was
written I like you know if I wanted to
see a spider-man movie would be this guy
I want to see what he was doing I liked
him in the movie I'm gonna piggyback on
it because this is the what if we made
it here we are you gotta add to other
people that question you will to hear
the answer they gave me that's just like
the creative possibilities out there are
just AB square where Jefferson the cop
who I see has both worlds he's being a
super power superhuman person and on the
side of the law but I would do it where
it's like the comic books that have the
the dots or over the dot I just realize
that I would do a claymation spider-man
I always think it's stopped I'm a twin
so I feel like what we don't have is a
spider-verse twin thing and I like scary
freaky like the matrix when they yeah
something like where they're just they
have different powers of not only
telekinetic powers powers of
invisibility how is it flight just like
every but also put my sweater minimal
Conda just so you know oh you guys
something about the process of working
with three directors on this movie are
they all in there there and Phil was
always in there too and Chris was always
hearing it and texting the information
and jokes and storylines thing into it
was I worked at times in
I've actually where there is a director
and a producer and writers and it feels
like it's too many people giving voices
and it gets confusing and that was not
this experience having all those people
in there they didn't overstep on each
other
and nobody was kind of the quote/unquote
Alpha in that room it's whoever was
talking who ever had passion to give a
note was right in that moment and that
was the person you were able to listen
to so if you know Peter was feeling
really passionate and I was doing a take
and he wanted to express something then
he and I would talk and everybody else
would just kind of listen and then if
Rodney got fired up Rodney would have it
so it almost felt like we got rather
than like a lot of directors giving you
notes
we just had multiple directors giving us
input so it actually made for this
animation way easier as an actor for me
I think that's why I turned out the way
it did because they had a five yeah five
different creative mods were all great
at what they do pouring in different
ideas into the part to create this idea
about the spider-verse of all these
different dimensions and universes and
it all came to this everyone of these
directors all three of the ones we got
and you know Chris and Phil I would be
interested to see a standalone movie
that they make because each one of them
is wildly talented and when you would
talk to him you would feel their talent
you'd feel their passion and what they
were bringing to it so this movie is
kind of cheating because it's getting
like an all-star team and they're all
just directing this one so you're like
oh each one of them could have had their
own spin-off they do I should be the
agent actually they were telling me that
you guys had some props you could work
with in the room I heard that they kind
of mocked built a police car where at
least parts of it so I was wondering
what are the what other physical things
you had in the sound booth with you that
you could use because that sounded a
little unusual
have anything but what we were able to
do which was really nice and which
doesn't happen a lot of these is we were
able to do it together a bunch and when
we did that we would do full scenes and
they wired us both and miked us both so
that we could move around and you could
talk and you could do it like we were
doing it in live-action we were able to
do full scenes together and improvise
and open it up and then they would
animate around that stuff and so that
was a really unique thing with animation
I'd never done before
[Music]